é normal fezes moles e dor de barriga
tomando magnésio quelado sim é bem comum
melhor diminuir a dose certamente a
suplementação com magnésio ele pode
causar sim o intestino solto ele é muito
bom para vários benefícios de saúde vai
reduzir estresse melhorar o sono dar
suporte ao sistema muscular porém um
efeito colateral muito comum do magnésio
é fezes moles e dor de barriga Por que
acontece isso por que que esse é um
efeito colat é o comum do magnésio é
porque o magnésio em concentrações altas
ele pode chamar água para dentro do do
da Luz intestinal ele vai aumentar a
água que tem nos intestinos isso Vai
facilitar a passagem de fezes mas também
pode causar a diarreia em
exagero então é muito importante você
tomar cuidado com a dose porque a dor de
barriga pode ser sim um sintoma
associado a esse uso porque vai alterar
o ritmo intestinal então se você Tá
experimentando esses sintomas por
enquanto diminua a dose do magnésio e
busque outras alternativas né então é
importante você tomar outras formas de
magnésio que possam ter menos efeito
laxativo por exemplo você pode escolher
o magnésio glicina ou magnésio de malato
que são formas menos propensas de causar
a diarreia